well for the first time in two years  local housing prices have gone down las  vegas realtors report the average price  for a home in june 480 thousand dollars  a slight drop from the record set in may  still prices are more than 20 percent  higher than a year ago condo and  townhome prices also dropped about five  thousand dollars what's contributing  interest rates are increasing and  inventory is up more than 5 700 homes  are on the market  while those prices are seeing a slight  drop here that is not the case for most  of the country mortgage debt is also on  the rise and millennials seem to be  paying more the average millennial owes  11 percent more on their mortgage than  the average homeowner adding up to  roughly 255 000 over the course of that  loan millennials also have the second  highest mortgage debt just behind  generation x people ages 42 to 57.